new variant
as we have done throughout the past two
years we'll continue to work with the
devolved administrations as they decide
how to take forward their own plans
in england we will remove all remaining
domestic restrictions in law
from this thursday it will no longer be
law to self-isolate if you test positive
and so we will also end the provision of
self-isolation support payments although
statutory sick pay can still be claimed
for a further month
if you're a fully vaccinated close
contact or under 18 you will no longer
be asked to test daily for seven days
and if you're a close contact who is not
fully vaccinated you will no longer be
required
to self-isolate
until april the first we will still
advise you to stay at home if you test
positive but after that we will
encourage people with covid with copied
symptoms to exercise personal
responsibility just as we encourage
people who may have flu to be
considerate towards others
it's only because levels of immunity are
so high and deaths are now if anything
below where you would normally expect
for this time of year that we can lift
these restrictions
and it's only because we know
omicron is less severe
that testing for omicron on the colossal
scale that we have been doing
is now much less valuable in
preventing serious illness
we should be proud that the uk
established the biggest testing program
per person of any large country in the
world
but its budget
in the last financial year was bigger
than that of the home office and it cost
the testing program cost 2 billion
pounds just
last month alone
so we must scale back and prioritize our
resources for the most vulnerable
from today staff and students in most
education and child care settings will
no longer be asked to undertake twice
weekly asymptomatic testing
and from the first of april we will end
free symptomatic and asymptomatic
testing for the general public but we
will continue providing free symptomatic
tests to those of the highest risk from
covid and in line with the practice of
many other countries we're working with
retailers to ensure you will always be
able to buy a test
we should be clear
that the pandemic
is not
over
and there may be significant resurgences
our scientists are certain that there
will be new variants and it is very
possible that those will be worse than
omicron
so we will continue to protect the most
vulnerable with targeted vaccinations
and treatments and we've bought enough
doses of vaccine to anticipate a wide
range of possible jcvi recommendations
today this includes a new spring booster
which will be offered to those age 75
and over older care home residents and
those over 12 who are immunosuppressed
we will also retain disease surveillance
systems and contingency measures which
can ensure our resilience in the face of
future waves or new variants
and we will build on the innovations
that defined the very best of our
response to the pandemic including
continuing the work of the vaccines task
force which has already secured
contracts with manufacturers trialling
new vaccines which could provide
protection against new variants
today is not the day we can declare
victory over kovid because this virus is
not
going away but
it is the day
when all the efforts of the last two
years
finally enabled us to protect ourselves
whilst restoring our liberties in full
and after two of the darkest grimmest
years in our peacetime history i do
believe this is a moment of pride for
our nation and
a source of hope for all that we can
achieve in the years to come
thank you very much i think patrick's
gonna be chris christie
thank you thank you prime minister first
slide please
uh the first slides are ones uh which
has been shown before but updated uh so
the first slide is the number of people
testing positive for covid uh in the uk
and as you can see although the um
the omicron wave is now going down it
reached an extraordinarily high peak and
the number of people still with omicron
is still very high and people including
elderly and vulnerable people are still
being
infected
next slide please
the number of people in hospital uh with
kovid in the uk
is again still significant and this is
still in many hospitals providing quite
a lot of pressure uh on nhs services but
the rates are now going down and have
been going down steadily uh now for some
weeks
i think it's important to acknowledge
that as with the last peak
and this in this peak it would have been
considerably higher had people not
listen to advice and been careful
not to transmit to other people where it
was avoidable in particularly to protect
vulnerable people so this is i just
wanted to say this would have been a lot
worse uh without that but this peak was
significant in hospitalizations and
those who say that this is a trivial
disease i think need to look at how many
people were in hospital and still are
going into hospital with omicron
next slide please
on the other hand fortunately the number
of people who have died
with a positive test for omicron and of
course some of these will not have died
obamacron but many have
was much smaller than the previous peak
although every death uh is a tragedy for
the individual and for the families
this is now steadily going down
next slide please
and
as a result of the extraordinary work of
the nhs volunteers and people coming
forward we had a very rapid increase in
boosting
which
the fact that people were able to take
precautions
before and around christmas time bought
time for for the boosting of the
population and in particular the
boosting of the elderly and vulnerable
population this is continuing people are
still coming forward for their first
second and booster vaccinations
but that extraordinary upswing uh saved
many people from gained hospital and
will have saved also many lives next
slide please
i just wanted to make a couple of
comments on the impact of vaccination on
severity
there is no doubt that even with omicron
which is a less severe variant in the
vaccinated being vaccinated
significantly reduces in every age band
the risk of gained hospitalization into
hospital and this is
shown on this graph here and if you look
around the world at countries where
omicron waves are ongoing
and where elderly populations have lower
vaccination rates the rate of
hospitalization is substantially higher
next slide please
i think even more striking is what
happens when we get in to the most
severe patients who go into
intensive care icu
and what this graph shows up going up to
the age of 70 after that the data
becomes slightly less easily interpret
because of confounding factors but what
you can see is the purple bars are the
people is the proportions relative to
the population who are unvaccinated
and the very low bars there
that you can see almost invisible
are the proportions relative to the
population in people who are vaccinated
with a first second or boosted dose
demonstrating really clearly
that
you can be hospitalized you can go
through icu but that vaccination is a
very substantial protection
next slide please
i'd find like to just make a couple of
comments on the relative importance of
omicron as a cause of mortality uh at
the moment
and if you this the first way of showing
this is looking all the way back to the
beginning of the pandemic
and this is showing weekly registered
deaths this is all deaths this is not
just covides and in orange are the ones
where covert is mentioned on the death
certificate
and what you can see is really big peaks
which occurred in the first
and second waves and a prolonged but
much lower peak uh in the delta wave due
to vaccination
and then you still have people who are
uh dying with cobit at the moment but
the dotted line
the purple line
is the average number of people you
would expect to be dying at this time of
year and as you can see the total number
of deaths now if you combine omicron
and everything else is now slightly
lower
than the average seasonal average you
would expect at this time of year and to
show this a slightly different before i
pass on actually just to point out very
large numbers of people much higher
proportion are dying of other things and
that is a key part of the considerations
for how we need to think about the next
nine months
last slide please
and this is a slightly different way of
showing the same data
and what it shows is the really
extraordinarily large waves of excess
mortality this is for all causes
that coincided with the first second and
delta waves
but actually relatively small uh impact
in fact in absolute terms a slight
decrease relative to the average for
this time of year over the five years
over the years that preceded the
the kobe pandemic
so i thought it was just worth
highlighting that
because this does demonstrate that in a
highly vaccinated population with
omicron which is a less severe variant
than previous ones the impact on overall
all chords mortality has been much more
muted in fact essentially not
visible compared to the previous waves
now i thought because there are some
changes now i'd just like to make some
additional
kind of forward views about what's going
to happen and then
patrick is going to add a few as well
the first is just to say something about
the omicron wave the omicron wave is
still high
and if you look around the uk we're
still in places with still between uh
one in 20 and one in 25 people have got
omicron if they were tested according to
ns data which is slightly backward
looking now the rates are coming down
but this is still a very common
infection
and it is important to
view the next
period
when we will still have testing all the
way up to april
and which
changes are happening in fact in steps
people think about this as one big step
this is a gradual steady change
over a period of time as the rates are
going down and as we head into spring
and i think it's important to understand
that context this is not a sudden
everything stops this is a steady move
the next thing it's important to
acknowledge is that we all expect and
patrick will talk more about this there
to be new variants
and some of those new variants will just
disappear but some of them will cause us
significant problems and they could be
either more vaccine escaping but as
severe as omicron but the net effect
would be
actually more people end up in hospital
because a lot of our protections are
from vaccination or it could be more
intrinsically severe
because omicron came from a much earlier
variant and patrick will talk a bit
about a bit more about this so we could
certainly end up with something which is
more uh
more likely to lead to hospitalizations
than normal crime and therefore we need
to be very careful as the prime minister
said and have our both our surveillance
and our uh mobility to ramp up with us
and then finally just as the good news
is things are going down as we head into
spring we do have to accept that the
respiratory season next winter and in
subsequent winters it's likely to
combine coved whatever variants are
circulating there flu and all the other
respiratory problems so
we expect the winters to be tricky even
in the absence of significant new
variants and we again the vaccination
program that jccvi will consider
will take that into account
now the implications of this are
as we look at the next weeks we still
have high rates of omicron
and
i would urge people in terms of public
health advice and this is very much the
government's position i'm
that people should still if they have
coveted
uh try to prevent other people getting
it and that means self-isolating so that
is the public health advice it would
have been the public health advice and
will be the public health advice for
multiple other diseases if you had no
reverse we would give exactly the same
public health advice so this is standard
public health advice for a significant
and highly transmissible infection
all the things that
people have
done so well and have thought about so
systematically remain important
maximizing ventilation
hand washing
and
for the period when there are still
significant numbers of cases at least
using masks in enclosed uh
spaces with large numbers of other
people is a sensible way of helping to
reduce the risk to others
as rates go down that that will the the
relative benefit to these kind of things
will change but at this point while the
rates are very high this remains
sensible pragmatic advice which
everybody knows about and everybody can
continue to follow and this is part of
the steady movement towards a new phase
of managing this virus
and we must have three things we must
have good surveillance as the prime
minister said to ensure that when new
variants start to take off when we start
to see new surges we know where they are
and we can respond in a targeted and
rapid way to make sure we deal with them
before they cause significant problems
for individuals and for the nhs
we must have the capacity rapidly to
step up
uh in terms of what we're doing and we
must be able to protect the most
vulnerable and those really are the
critical things that we need to maintain
even beyond the uh this next few weeks a
few weeks into
the rest of this year and the rest of
the way that we continue to manage this
epidemic patrick was going to expand a
bit on the issues uh in particular
around around uh variation
yeah thank you so
very clear this pandemic is not over and
it's carrying on around the world and
we're not out of it here yet
the virus is continuing to evolve
so
every variant is an evolution
and
the virus has got a lot of room to
evolve
and it will continue to do so quite fast
probably for the next couple of years
those changes
will
alter the properties of the virus there
is no guarantee that the next variant
is
as
reduced severity as omicron
it could be the same it could be more
could be less
so as it evolves what it's trying to do
is transmit more readily to grow so that
could be because it has got intrinsic
transmissibility advantage
or it escapes immunity
and the change in severity
is a random byproduct
so we expect there to be further
variance and they could be more severe
as chris has said if you look at omicron
actually
with the immunity we've got in the
population
the level of severe illness and death
has been dramatically reduced
and that's the reason across the world
people are beginning to release measures
it's not just here everyone is beginning
to release measures
but in order to do that safely
there are some things that need to be in
place
the first is it's absolutely essential
to have
a way of detecting it a good
surveillance system
and we're lucky that we have a very good
surveillance system in this country the
ons study
which is a way of picking up across the
population both at a national level and
at a regional level and in different age
groups
what is happening and that detection
system is going to be vital
the second thing that's important
is being able to respond quickly
so the resilience and the ability to
ramp up is absolutely crucial and that
doesn't mean ramp up over months if
something goes wrong you need to be able
to ramp up very quickly just remember
how quickly omicron took off
that tells you you've got a couple of
weeks to get things back in action
so once you take things off
it's going to be important to know how
quickly you can put them back on again
and to get them back in shape in time to
be able to deal with it
and the third
is throughout all of that
there's a sections of the population who
remain vulnerable at all times and it's
important that they are protected both
in terms of their ability to detect the
illness
the ability to get antiviral treatments
quickly and of course the protection
that everyone gets from vaccination
so detect respond
and protect the most vulnerable is
absolutely crucial during a period of
reducing
the measures that are in place
and being careful about how that goes in
relation to what is an evolving virus
with a period of quite unstable
evolution over the next year or more
these measures are going to be important
to give the safety net and as
an american colleague put it at the
weekend he said you can celebrate when
the sun's shining but take your umbrella
with you and i think that's really the
message
good i think i think that sums it up
very well thank you very much let's get
the questions from the from the from the
public first nicole from the west
midlands
looking at the data it would appear that
covid19 hospitalizations
are currently
and
and we are going to stick with the uh
questions at that press conference but
uh i should just tell you that vladimir
putin
is still speaking about ukraine it is a
long speech it is a rambling speech but
it is uh contains a lot that is
threatening to ukraine we are still
across that here in eastern ukraine and
we will stay across that but we will go
back to the questions that is uh that
are being asked of uh boris johnson
downward trend and the number of people
in icu uh is is as a proportion of those
going into hospital is much much uh
smaller and and you'll have seen the uh
the fatality uh numbers that were we're
seeing which are very different from
what we experienced under uh under
previous waves so uh it's clear that
omicron is uh is very different and and
and and milder in the way that it
behaves that's one of the reasons in
addition to the vaccines uh that we have
uh the high level of vaccine-induced uh
and other immunity that's one of the
reasons we can do what we're doing but
um chris and i completely agree that
obviously the prime minister's answer i
mean i think the two the
three things of knowledge the first of
which is it is certainly the case that
there are hospitals in the uk which are
still under significant pressure as a
result of omicron and i think we should
be really clear about that but and this
is the big difference the trajectory the
first big difference the trajectory is
definitely down at the moment and it is
steadily down and has been for some time
a way to go but that is the direction of
travel very different to where we found
ourselves in previous periods and
secondly the number of the proportion of
those people who having entered hospital
then end up in intensive care or getting
into deep trouble and in some cases
sadly dying is a very very much much
smaller proportion as a result of
vaccination
which we didn't have uh in october 2020
and of a less severe variant
thanks gemma from greater london
as a pregnant woman i'm told by the nhs
website that i'm more likely to suffer a
serious illness if i catch covid and in
the third trimester it could also affect
my baby
with the plans to remove cover
restrictions being brought forward what
are the recommendations for women like
me and for other clinically vulnerable
people
for the sake of removing social
distancing and wearing masks are we
effectively being told to stay inside
and remove ourselves from the world
gemma no and i think that
what everybody needs to do is make sure
that
they treat people who may be uh
vulnerable
in any way uh with the utmost uh
consideration and
uh and and you know we've we've gotta
we've gotta if we if we're
symptomatic with any disease you should
you should you should treat vulnerable
people uh with uh
uh
with courtesy and and avoid avoid
spreading it what we also want to make
sure is that people who are cleanly
vulnerable do continue to have access uh
to uh to tests uh so that uh they can
know whether they may have uh covid and
and also get the the therapeutics that
they they need
depending on what their and what their
condition is
um but i collected one point uh prime
minister which is uh it is really clear
now that uh vaccination in pregnancy is
a very good thing to do for you
a very good thing to do for your unborn
baby and new data demonstrating that
it's actually also a very good thing to
do for your newborn baby there is now
data that that shows that it provides
protection for newborns so essentially
it's protecting both you and your baby
and i would really really want to use
the opportunity gem of your question to
encourage anybody who is pregnant and
has not been vaccinated pleased to do so
yeah that that is a very good because
there was a while when there was quite a
lot of folklore against vaccination for
uh pregnant women and that was really
not not right at all
um thanks very much uh laura coonsburg
bbc news
thank you prime minister um you are
scrapping free tests for all
but you're telling everybody they have
to take personal responsibility how can
people take personal responsibility if
they may not be able to afford to get a
covered test even if they're trying to
and you accept that you're giving
scotland northern ireland and wales
really no choice but to do the same
because there won't be additional money
for testing and to sir chris and sir
patrick you know many times you've
talked about how a lack of testing early
on
hampered the attempts to save lives now
there are enough tests but the
government is no longer going to fund
free tests for all i know you've both
emphasized the need for good
surveillance but testing is being scaled
back do you worry that in time
that could prove to be a mistake and
just forgive me prime minister as we've
as you've been speaking president putin
has been talking um could you respond to
his claim to recognize the two um
separatist breakaway republics yes uh
sure so uh so thanks laura look on on on
testing that the only reason and first
of all
let's be clear we're not uh ending it
ending uh free lateral flow tests now uh
the there are several more weeks still
to to go we won't we won't do it until
the beginning of of april uh we can only
do that because of the reasons that uh
chris and patrick have set out the uh
the high level of immunity uh the the
relative uh mildness of of omicron uh
the the low level of uh the numbers of
people in icu and the low mortality
we're seeing so that that's the reason
we can address omicron uh in this way
but what we will do is make sure that
there will be uh people who continue to
get uh testing vulnerable uh people will
continue to to have access to testing
and uh to pre-test but the most
important thing is that
and i hope this is the big take out from
this uh
it's the sun is shining but we're
keeping our umbrella as patrick said at
the end of this at the end of his
remarks
we were going to make sure that we
invest in in surveillance and the ons
survey is it really is world class it's
a mode around the world it gives a lot
of very granular data about uh where uh
cases are uh uh uh breaking out uh
patterns across the across the uk we
will keep that going we'll keep
observing what is happening because we
want to have uh the the keenest pair of
eyes in the in the crow's nest to watch
for the uh the iceberg in the form of a
new variant and that's that's the thing
that's the thing you've really got to to
test for and uh and the
the big surveillance uh tests of the way
uh to do that
and uh if we see
something like that
then that's the moment to get to uh
patrick's point that's when we ramp up
and we we immediately go uh back to all
the things that we have learned to to do
so we have we'll have a stockpile of
of lfds of lateral flow tests we can we
can make at least some of them already
in this uh in this country we have the
we have labs that will keep going like
the rosalind franklin lab uh mobile
testing units and so on so
what we want is
to have a formula of of surveillance
followed by surge uh if if necessary but
we we can only take the
uh the the strategy only adopt the
strategy we're adopting today because of
the success of the of the vaccines and
the way uh omicron is currently
responding and sorry on ukraine
i i um
just to say uh
i i gather just as i came into this
press conference that vladimir putin has
effectively announced that
russia is
recognizing
the breakaway republics
of donetsk and lugansk
this is plainly in breach of
international law
it's a violation
flagrant violation of the sovereignty
and integrity of the
uh of ukraine uh
it is a repudiation
of the
of the minx process and the minsk
agreements
and uh i think it's a very
ill omen and a very dark sign
and it certainly does not seem to me
that it's certainly
an indication uh yet another indication
uh that things are moving in the wrong
direction in ukraine the uk will
continue to do everything we can to
stand by the people of of ukraine uh
with a very robust package of sanctions
as you know uh
fortifying the eastern flank of nato in
all the ways that we have
but also being one of the few countries
to have given the ukrainians the
defensive i stressed defensive uh
weaponry uh that we think is is
appropriate to their to their needs and
we will continue to to to think about
what more we can do uh to support
ukraine in what is clearly a very very
dark and difficult time
i know there was a question for you
in terms of on the testing um the
essentially three reasons for testing
the surveillance and i think the
intention as the prime minister has said
is to continue surveillance there will
be some modification to that but the aim
is to have a good surveillance system
because you need that for policy
decisions
the second reason is clinical to guide
treatment expectations continue that in
the nhs
there are questions about exactly how we
do do this in terms of uh getting
antivirals to the people who most need
them and that's a key
decision that needs to be taken over the
next
period
and then the third reason and this is
the one that is being scaled back but
not yet but will be scaled back uh is
the is using them for control but as the
prime minister said uh as and when the
surveillance shows you need it
what everybody has stressed is there's
the need to be able to stand things up
again if necessary were there to be
something that's severe enough to need
it so it's that third area where the
biggest changes will really occur
i mean i don't think anywhere across the
world where restrictions are being
relaxed
you can have any other view other than
that will increase transmission
so that is
inevitable as you go back to normal life
that transmission risk increases
at the beginning
we just didn't have tests
we've now got tests unfortunately we've
got lateral flow tests which can be
stored and released very quickly and so
it's going to really have to be this
rapid detection
and response
at scale
in order to get testing into the right
place depending on what the
circumstances are and as
chris has uh indicated at the moment
with omicron i mean it's spread very
widely it hasn't caused
huge numbers it has caused some and it
has in other countries caused quite a
lot but in this country hasn't got huge
numbers of very ill people
or deaths
if that changes then obviously testing
becomes more important in the meantime
the testing must be there for people who
need it and that definition of people
who are in that at-risk group is
critical for appropriate use of testing
thanks robert peston itv
um
a couple of questions on ukraine the
recognition of lugansk and donnie is a
clear violation of international law as
you say it's accelerating the breakup of
ukraine
surely this is the moment to introduce
additional
severe
sanctions the time for waiting must be
passed
um
and on what you've announced today um a
couple of questions one is after april
the first if you get covered will you
isolate
uh secondly
um
you introduced sorry you you announced
today the end
of the self isolation support package
and within a few weeks you won't be able
to get statuses sick pay on day
one
you are making it harder for poorer
people to do what you think is the right
thing which is to isolate if they get
covered
so
fine thanks robert very much so on on
the
um
uh the statutory sick pay issue first of
all and
and
we will continue with the day one uh
payments uh for the next few weeks uh
but
i think after that what we need to to
recognize is that we're effectively
dealing with a uh particularly in
vaccinated people with a
a disease that is that is
like norovirus or uh or flu or
any other infectious respiratory
disease and people should
think about how they
interact with others and they should be
uh respectful of other people's health
and
and behave responsibly and that and that
goes for any the point i'm trying to
make is that goes for uh for any uh
infectious uh disease which you might be
bringing into uh into contact with
people who uh who are vulnerable i think
you know in this country
i've often heard it said over the last
couple of years that we uh we have a
habit of of going back to work or going
into work uh when uh
were
we're not well
people contrast that with germany for
instance who uh where uh
i'm told uh
they're much more disciplined about not
going to work if you're if you're sick
and i'm just i'm just suggesting that
that might be the uh uh something we
could we could learn and as for me i
will i will i will i will
exercise restraint and responsibility
and try to avoid infecting infecting
other people and on on your um
your point about sanctions
um
look we have to see what exactly has
happened in uh dunyetsk and lugansk in
the donbass area um
what i have said before
about the package of sanctions is that
they will be triggered with the first
toe cap
of a
russian incursion or russian
invasion
but plainly what has happened is
extremely bad news
and we will be urgently talking to uh
our friends and allies uh around the
world all of whom are uh
jointly signed up with us in this
package
of sanctions because it is it is i mean
i think you know i think the drift of
your
question is right it is becoming clear
that we're going to need to start
applying as much pressure as we possibly
can because it is it is hard to see how
this
situation uh improves
uh let's go to um bear through b of sky
thank you um
prime minister just to follow up on
ukraine ten days ago at nato i asked you
if you were coming to the conclusion
that president putin actually wants this
war at the time you said i honestly
don't think a decision has been made
what do you think tonight how has that
changed and on
the matter of pavid prime minister
you've spoken about hope tonight and the
country getting its confidence back
but to sir patrick
uh sir patrick and sir chris
it seems to me that you're clear you're
making it clear that this pandemic is
far from over what are you feeling are
you more anxious
than confident as these restrictions are
dropped and and to the prime minister
you know we've been doing these press
conferences now on code for two years
covid has dominated your premiership it
put you in hospital it could bring about
your downfall depending on the outcome
of that met investigation
and today it seems that you're trying to
turn the page but would you be satisfied
if your legacy ends up being covered and
your conduct during it thank you uh yeah
so uh
first of all on
uh on your your question about about
covered and i think uh
chris and patrick may want to talk about
anxiety look i think that um
the the country as a whole
when you look at the
uh
the response to
the government was able to mount to
coven
and you look at what the country has
done uh i think the two things have
have gone together and i think it's been
quite remarkable if you look at the the
look at the numbers at the back of the
living with covid uh document about
uh vaccination rates uh rollouts uh what
we've been able to do
uh we we were
incredibly fast and that was a joint
work of the of the british uh public uh
and and the government uh the public
were absolutely heroic uh in what they
did and
um
you know i will be very very proud of
what has been achieved
to be to be frank with you but um
on the anxiety point
i i don't want you to think that there's
some
you know uh
division between uh the the the gung-ho
politicians and the cautious anxious
scientists uh much they may suit
everybody to say so
we we have a a
a very clear view of this this has not
gone away uh we're able to make these
changes now because of the of the
vaccines and the high level of immunity
and all the other considerations about
omicron that you've seen
um
but
we have to face the fact that there
could be
likely will be
another variant
that will cause us trouble
but
i believe that thanks to a lot of the
stuff that we've done particularly
investment in
in vaccines and vaccine technology
and and therapeutics we'll be in a far
better position to tackle uh that new
variant when it comes
and on your question about uh about
putin and you know
i don't know what's in his mind i can't
read it
i think there's sort of chance that he
uh could roll back from this and we've
got to we've got to pray that that's the
case
in terms of uh anxious
well we can leave that press conference
just for the moment take you to moscow
and find out exactly what is in vladimir
putin's mind because he has
not only announced the formal
recognition of these breakaway republics
in
southeast ukraine he has signed the
decree
doing so so no question about it now
he has signed the decree formally
recognizing these breakaway republics
which are effectively part of ukraine a
pretty clear violation of international
law and effectively
another land grab on ukraine and where
it all leaves us is uh
well it's very difficult to tell how the
west will
react to this it was he spoke for about
an hour it was a very long speech